lou anne 16 ans et déjà la grâce d'une
future danseuse étoile quand on connaît
aujourd'hui son parcours on se dit
qu'elle a bien fait de croire en ses
rêves depuis un an et demi la jeune
femme est élève du ballet national
cubain une concrétisation
après tant d'années d'efforts
honnêtement j'étais un peu j'étais
vraiment surprise parce que je ne
pensais pas être acceptée par mon niveau
parce que à l'école de danse le niveau
est très élevé et j'étais vraiment très
heureuse
[Musique]
en arrivant là bas luan est devenue la
première française à intégrer l'école
elle y côtoie des danseurs du monde
entier et en quelques mois elle s'est
hissée à leur niveau elle profite ainsi
d'un apprentissage afro caribéens
ça me permet d'apprendre de nouvelles
cultures de connaître de nouvelles
personnes d'un connaître une nouvelle
langue aussi et ça me permet d'apprendre
aussi de nouvelles techniques
on pense alors que j'ai toujours appris
la technique française
débarqué dans un pays étranger n'a pas
été si simple
au delà de la barrière de la langue la
jeune femme doit gérer un rythme effréné
entre les cours de danse et la poursuite
de ses études par correspondance
si on s'arrête vraiment qu à kahone
quand on voit son évolution son
épanouissement
il n'y a pas photo c'est on serait à
refaire on l'aurait fait sans hésiter
non elle très très bien adapté bien
épanouie moins timide allant vers les
gens et puis et puis non très très très
positif devenir élève de l'école
nationale d'alicia alonso est une
opportunité incroyable
néanmoins l'excellence à un coup près de
25000 euros par an pour l'école le
logement l'alimentation les transports
un sacrifice financier pour toute la
famille
dès l'âge de 5 ans a déjà l'avait déjà
dit qu'elle ferait dans ce stock
on a suivi le mouvement donc je constate
qu'elle tient société as tu joues à
ventiler et puis on s'encourage on
essaie de se serrer la ceinture
on fait ce qu'on a dans trois ans lohan
sera une danseuse professionnelle elle
pourra auditionner dans les bals et du
monde entier et dans sera peut-être à
l'american ballet theater un autre rêve
de petite fille
[Musique]
e